[Music]  comfortable love you  [Music]  there is the cruelest presence most  unusual punishment my right heart should  fall into it  and your ball imprison you don't know  what to do through working on getting  you out of here for you in for solve  endeavor well now what you're going to  do I'm trying to be a writer you know  teach these kids not to make the same  mistakes I did  I got a car little hot you can need to  be up in Portland by Friday can't do  just not me no war when I wake up in the  morning I want to see you I want to see  that kid you know we don't have nowhere  else to stay  you don't know what you're gonna see  I need to stop you from ever spreading  again make sure we make you go back to a  feast but you know my loss  and otherwise just don't distribute  do I have to do for my son pays with the  head  [Music]  you  [Music]